[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public scena on est
ensemble du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
16 octobre Gaza toujours coupé du monde
et sous les bombes dans la crainte de
l'offensive terrestre des soldats de le
corridor humanitaire n'est toujours pas
ouvert pour les centaines de milliers de
personnes qui puient vers le sud par
ailleurs le porte-parole de l'armée
israélienne parle désormais de 199
otages leur sort retarde-t-il la
décision du cabinet de guerre d'entrée
dans Gaza on analyse la stratégie
militaire et les risques d'extension du
conflit dans une minute et puis c'est
l'image du jour cette minute de silence
dans les écoles de France en mémoire de
Dominique Bernard ce professeur de
lettrre assassiné par un terroriste
islamiste
vendredi jamais la barbarie ne
l'emportera face au
savoir jamais la République ne pliera
face au terrorisme Mohamed mogoukov
était tout comme sa famille surveillée
par la DGSI pourquoi était-il
inexpulsable faut-il une nouvelle voie
pour mieux nous protéger de ce
terrorisme qui ne nécessite ni armes
sophistiquées ni organisation ni longue
préméditation on en débat dans 45
minutes mais d'abord ces alertes à la
roquette qui ont retenti à Jérusalem et
à telavive cet après-midi la séance
inaugurale du Parlement a été suspendue
et pendant ce temps à Gaza laaide
humanitaire est toujours bloqué Samia de
chir des camions remplis d'aide
humanitaire bloqué à l'entrée de la
bande de Gaza rien nentre et rien ne
sort du point de passage de Rafa à la
frontière égyptienne depuis le le 9
octobre l'enclave palestinienne est
soumise à un blocus total de l'État
hébreu qui ne laisse entrer ni eau ni
nourriture ni carburant ces dernières
heures des rapports font état de
l'autorisation de l'aide humanitaire
dans la bande de Gaza en échange de
l'autorisation de sortie des étrangers à
ce stade je tiens à préciser que les
points de passage sont fermés et
qu'aucune décision de ce type n'a été
prise il n'y a pas de cesser le feu et
nous poursuivons notre activité
opérationnelle l'Autorité palestinienne
en app à la comm
internationale nous demandons à tous les
pays concernés d'intervenir
immédiatement afin d'ouvrir des passages
sûr pour l'acheminement de matériel
médical de nourriture et l'évacuation
des blessés les hôpitaux sont bondés il
y a plus de 11000
blessés l'ONU demande également
l'ouverture d'un corridor 1 million de
personnes soit la moitié de la
population de l'enclave palestinienne a
fui le nord pour échapper à l'assaut
terrestre qu'Israël s'apprête à y lancer
il désormais dans le sud sans
électricité impossible de faire tourner
les hôpitaux l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé une
catastrophe en ce qui concerne l'eau
l'électricité le carburant selon l' la
Croix Rouge et le Croissant rouge après
24 he ce sera une véritable catastrophe
pas de carburant donc pas d'électricité
pour tous les habitants de la bande de
Gaza en général et pour les
établissements médicau en particulier
les frappes israéliennes ont fait au
moins 2750 morts palestiniens côté
israélien le bilan de l'attaque du Hamas
du 7 octobre dépasse désormais les 1400
morts et près de 200 otages cet
après-midi des roquettes ont été
intercepté au-dessus de Jérusalem la
séance du parlement a dû être suspendue
pour la mise à l'abri des
députés et on va commencer justement par
cette dernière information c'est sirènes
qui ont retenti à TelAviv et Jérusalem
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Jérôme clèche bonsoir bienvenue
bonsoir vous êtes ê enseignant en
prospective stratégie et stratégie à la
science pour Paris et puis auteur de ce
livre la prospective stratégique aux
éditions Herman myiam benrad bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
chercheuse à sciencesp centre de
recherche internationale de de Sciences
Po et à l'Institut de recherche et
d'études sur les mondes arabes et
musulmans Antoine Mariotti bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste France
24 ancien correspondant à Jérusalem et
Mathieu croissandau bonssoir mathieuir
éditorialiste politique bienvenue à à
vous Jérôme clche ses alertes à la
roquette sur sur télavive et et
Jérusalem ça veut dire que le Hamas a
encore encore un arsenal bah encore un
arsenal bien sûr que tout n'a pas été
détruit il y a une semaine de frappe
aérienne 6000 bombes presque autant
d'objectifs de cible du Hamas qui ont
été détruites avec notamment deux des
chefs du Hamas dont l'organisateur des
attentats des massacre du 7 octobre
dernier néanmoins tout n'est pas détruit
et c'est aussi le sens non seulement des
frappes aériennes qui se poursuivent
sauf au sud puisque Israël a annoncé
sinon un cesser le feu en tout cas de
suspendre les frappes au sud pour
inciter faciliter le déplacement des
populations Gazaoui du nord vers le sud
et puis c'est aussi le sens de cette
préparation de cette offensive terrestre
que l'on dit imminente sur lequel nous
sur laquelle nous reviendrons et et qui
a vocation à pour dire les choses très
clairement à finir le travail
c'est-à-dire à neutraliser euh
l'ensemble de l'arsenal du Hamas et puis
nous y reviendrons aussi qui vise
probablement aussi la la libération des
otages oui on parlera évidemment des
otages et de cette offensive terrestre
il y a déjà eu alors évidemment les
bilans évoluent et
malheureusement selon les sources
palestiniennes 2750 morts 9700 blessés
dans les frappes israéliennes miram
benrad mais on vient d'en parler
l'organisation terroriste du Hamas
continue de d'avoir la capacité de de
frapper ou de viser Israël ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que c'était préparé à
un conflit de longue durée B moi je
pense tout de même qu'il y a un décalage
entre cette riposte israélienne qui
s'est faite disons-le sur un mode
talionique
vengeur qui a finalement décideré
d'infliger une punition collective à la
bande de Gaza puisque dans l'esprit des
dirigeants israéliens toute la bande de
Gaza a fait le jeu du Hamas et donc
porte la responsabilité du massacre qui
a été commis mais euh je ne pense pas en
réalité que ce à quoi on assiste est une
opération qui sera efficace je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que pour le moment
on pilonne h mais euh on ne sait pas moi
je n'ai pas en tout cas d'information
quant au nombre de militant du Hamas tué
dans ces frappes on nous annonce que
l'infrastructure a été détruite je n'ai
pas non plus d'information propante
d'ailleurs l'armée israélienne ne va pas
communiquer outre mesure puisqu'ils sont
en train d'organiser tout ça il va avoir
une offensive terrestre donc pour des
questions de renseignement et de
confidentialité aussi évidemment ils
vont pas renseigner l'ennemi en pleine
opération donc on ne sait pas
véritablement ce qui se passe il y a
aussi se présupposer chez les Israéliens
qu'en quelque sorte le Hamas se
concentrerait dans le Nord donc on donne
l'instruction aux populations d'aller
vers le sud or l'attaque du Hamas en
territoire israélien qui a pris tout le
monde de cours elle montre qu'on n sait
pas grand-chose finalement enfin que ce
mouvement se reconfigure se restructure
se déplace de manière très fluide c'est
une c'est un mouvement au-delà du
caractère terroriste des opérations
qu'il mène c'est un mouvement insurgé
c'est une menace asymétrique donc je je
trouve qu'il y a un décalage entre ce
que les Israéliens nous annoncent et ce
à quoi on assiste sans compil faire
autrement je vais redonner la parole
juste après oui bien sûr les civiles
j'en ai parlé Antoine Mariotti
effectivement c'est la loi dualon c'est
la vengeance bon on peut toujours dire
que Benjamin N vous aurz pu choisir une
autre une autre stratégie ça semble
difficilement envisageable et vous qui
connaissez bien la société israélienne
esttait-ce envisageable c'est très
compliqué parce que vous avez évidemment
une pression populaire une pression
politique et puis surtout Benjamin
netanahou s'est construit depuis une
vingtaine d'années une sorte de mythe du
monsieur sécurité d'Israël comme quoi il
serait le seul rempart contre le
terrorisme et cetera ce myth là c'est
complètement effondré il y a une semaine
ça fait quand même des années qu'on est
nombreux à dire attendez il y a beaucoup
de discours dans les actes beaucoup
moins euh je vous prends un exemple très
concret moi j'étais à plusieurs reprises
dans la bande de Gaza un jour j'étais
pour faire un reportage sur tout à fait
autre chose il se trouve qu'il y a des
requettes qui sont tirés depuis la bande
de Gaza donc vers le territoire
israélien et là les Israéliens rostent
comme à chaque fois et nous annoncent
qu'ils ont détruit je ne sais plus quel
ministère je vais sur place dès que dès
que c'est possible et dès que notre
fixeur sur place nous dit que c'est
possible pour des raisons de sécurité
bon on se rend compte qu'en fait le
ministère est absolument intact en
revanche la guérite à côté elle du
gardien était complètement détruite et
c'est ça très souvent sauf que les
Israéliens ne rentrent pas la population
ne cherche pas forcément à savoir quel
est le détail n'ont pas forcément ces
informations là et et donc il y a
souvent eu un double jeu de Benjamin
netaniaou vis-à-vis du Hamas en en ne le
en ne faisant jamais en sorte de
réellement lui mettre un un coup fatal
et je vous rejoins totalement je trouve
qu'il est absolument impossible de
mettre un coup fatal à au has et c'est
tout le problème pardonnez-moi juste trs
sur cette question là c'est les
dirigeants israéliens sont en train de
faire des promesses qu'ils savent
pertinemment qu'ils ne pourront pas
tenir h la promesse de mettre un
termoamas a déjà été faite à mainte
reprise à chaque fois il revient encore
plus fort alors évidemment là on voit
les Israéliens qui s'apprêtent à taper
plus fort que d'habitude mais c'était la
même même problème avec le hbola en 2006
on nous avait dit qu'on allait détruire
l'infrastructure militaire du hzbolla
elle n'a jamais été aussi forte
qu'aujour vot Travis là-dessus cette
opération terè qui devrait commencer
dans les prochaines heures dans les
prochains jours on ne le sait pas est-ce
qu'ellez-vous à l'échec alors d'une part
il est pas du tout certain que cette
opération ait lieu ah vous pensez
qu'elle peut
ça peut encore être évité c'est une
solution de dernier recours en ce sens
que son objectif qui consisterait à
détruire le Hamas et à récupérer les
otages un objectif qui est quand même
assez exorbitant pour tout ce qui a été
dit concernant le Hamas et s'agissant
des otages elle aurait plutôt tendance à
mettre les otages en danger plutôt qu'à
les sauver donc c'est une solution de
dernier recours s'agissant aussi de
l'escalade possible avec d'autres front
symétrique qui s'ouvrirait comme celui
au nord avec le hzbollah Libanais où là
les tirs les échanges de tirs sont de
plus en plus nourris depuis une semaine
et pourquoi pas jusqu'au plateau du
Golan en Syrie puisque l'Iran l'a dit si
offensive terrestre elle l'a bien dit
offensive terrestre elle a été précise
il devait y avoir ce serait un casus
Belly et elle entrerait en guerre contre
contre Israël alors non pas directement
d'état à état puisque ça a été largement
dissuadé déjà par les déclarations des
États-Unis hein par la voix du chef de
la diplomatie Anthony blinken par la
voix de Joe Biden ça a été redit encore
là dans la tournée d'Anthony blinken et
puis aussi par l'arrivée des
portes-avions qui constituent de la
projection de puissance de nature à
dissuader un conflit d'état à état sur
le plan tout à fait mais sur le plan
asymétrique tout ça pourrait s'embraser
donc pour ces deux raisonslà l'offensive
terrestre est à éviter et et elle reste
quelque chose qui reste de nature du
dernier recours encore une fois si
offensif terrestre il devait y avoir ce
serait sans doute en creux en creux le
signe d'un échec de la diplomatie et des
voies aussi plus secrète que peuvent
emprunter les les discussions ça veut
dire plus de morts israélien d'ailleurs
si offensive oui bah parce qu'elle sera
forcément très compliqué à plus de
victimes collatéral égal les soldats et
les otages maie est-ce qu'on a une idée
des ressources du Hamas en terme de
matériel est-ce qu'on sait de de combien
d'armes il dispose et en terme de
soutien de la population alors ça fait
des années que le Hamas est armé par
l'Iran par entraîné et bénéfici du
transfert d'expertise du hzbollah
libanais financé par le Qatar avec
l'assentiment soit dit en passant
d'Israël enfin de benaminianaou
d'ailleurs ça c'est pour les transferts
financiers
l'entement globalement globalement
globalement il y a plusieurs dizaines de
milliers ça a été évalué mais ENF ça
prend avec des pincettes entre 30000 et
40000 roquettes des roquettes Cassam
donc c'est des roquettes extrêmement
rudimentaires hein ce sont des roquettes
artisanales qui tirent à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres qui partent sur
une rampe en faire c'est constitué sur
place il faut pas s'attendre en fait à
ça ressemble en rien au aux batteries
qui qui peut y avoir en Ukraine
typiquement hein sur puisque c'est le
dernier conflit que que sans doute les
médias ont en tête donc rien à voir avec
ça et c'est l'essentiel de l'armement
après pour ce qui est pour ce qui est de
des drones ce sont souvent des drones là
aussi d'emploi courant qui sont bricolés
de façon à pouvoir emporter des charges
explosives de moindre de moindre
finalement de moindre létalité et qui
servent à détruire soit des postes de
vidéosurveillance des choses comme ça
c'est ce qui a permis de passer le
grillage le 7 octobre on parlait du sort
des des otages leur nombre a été revu à
la hausse par l'armée israélienne on
écoute le porte-parole de
l'armée nous avons informé les familles
de 199
aotages
otages les efforts déployés en faveur
des otages constitue une priorité
nationale
absolue 199 FAM dans l'angoisse comme
cette femme dont la fille elle s'appelle
rom sa fille a été enlevé lors du
festival de musique supernova
ée nous ne savons rien d'autre elle a
disparu c'est tout ce que nous savons
maintenantous revienne nous voulons
qu'ell revienne vivante nous voulons
qu'elle revienne en bonne santé je pense
que ce qui s'est passé samedi dernier
est un homicide un crime contre
l'humanité s'il s'agit de romis il peut
s'agir d'un enfant en Turquie ou d'un
enfant au Qatar miram benral quels sont
les les menaces qui ont été proférées
par par le Hamas concernant ces ces
otages et et à quel point peuvent-ils
les mettre à à exécution d' bah les
menaces c'est tout simplement les tuer
hein les tuer si Israël n'accepte pas de
négocier on peut imaginer négocier la
libération de prisonniers comme ce fut
le cas de dans le passé le Hamas a déjà
annoncé que certains de ses otages
seraient décédés auraient perdu la vie
dans les frappes israéliennes on a aucun
moyen de vérifier en réalité on ne sait
pas où ils se trouvent est-ce qu'ils
sont dans les fameux sous-terrains
est-ce qu'ils sont dans quelle zone de
la bande de Gaza ont-ils été placés on a
très peu d'information le le problème
c'est qu'on en a peu par ailleurs encore
une fois l'armée israélienne n'a aucun
intérêt en réalité à partager trop
d'information avec le public si la
détermination de libérer ses otages ré
vos arguments aux uns et aux autres
pardon de vous interrompre mais que peut
faire alors je vais aller au-udelà de
l'armée israélienne le l'État d'Israël
aujourd'hui face à une telle menace à
ses portes je sais bien on a fait
plusieurs débats sur la responsabilité
le les les erreurs stratégiques de de
benamin Netanyahou et de certains de ses
prédécesseurs depuis des années qui
avaient choisi son meilleur et demi avec
le Hamas mais là on est en train de dire
militairement ça ne sert à enfin c'est
c'est quasiment VO à l'échec de rentrer
sur dans la bande de de de Gaza vu ce
qu'a subi le peuple israélien quelle
réponse pevent-il av aujourd'hui moi mon
avis c'est que on va continuer sur une
séquence de frappes arienne très lourde
qui consiste à mon avis au-delà de la si
vous voulez de la suppression enfin ce
sera pas une suppression donc mais on va
dire de la réduction de la menace à Mass
qui consistera tout de même aussi
politiquement à à mais c'est c'est c'est
comme ça que les Israéliens conçoivent
donner une leçon aux Palestiniens bon
encore une fois là rien rien n'est dit
est-ce que ça va apaiser la situation
est-ce qu'au contraire ça va générer de
nouvelles carrières militantes au
service du Hamas et d'autres groupes
armés tels le Djihad islamique on ne
sait pas mais j'aimerais quand même
peut-être dire une chose par rapport à
ce que ce que les Israéliens peuvent
faire une fois dans la bande de Gaza et
et j'aimerais avoir peut-être votre avis
sur la question moi il me semble qu' à
part euh envoyer des forces spéciales
monter des opérations extrêmement
sensibles pour essayer précisément
d'aller libérer les otages que
peuvent-ils faire alors en plus
évidemment des opérations plus lourdes
contre le Hamas je ne vois pas
réellement ce que cette armée va pouvoir
faire de plus bah très concrètement à
quoi faut s'attendre il faut s'attendre
à du combat urbain le combat urbain ça
renvoie pour faire cours mais ça vous
donnera une idée à ce qui s'est fait en
Afghanistan on peut pas dire que ce soit
vraiment un grand succès voilà bon
l'imbrication des populations entre les
si on peut dire la population c'està
dire les terroristes du Hamas et puis la
population civile Gazaoui elle est très
forte c'est très imbriqué il y a des
infrastructures et sans doute des stocks
et évidemment des tunnels et des postes
du Hamas mais il y a aussi une
imbrication très forte de ces deux de
ces deux populations et donc précisément
engager dans un tel combat l'offensive
terrestre ne peut un que faire beaucoup
de victimes collatérales de fait et puis
beaucoup de pertes du côté de et se
retrouve obligé et c'est le maître mot
obligé de faire de l'occupation et c'est
ça tout le problème en fait alors c'est
vous interr parce qu'on on va discuter
les uns et les autres autour de ce terme
occupation justement parce que c'est
l'une des questions qui a été posée à
Joe
bidenes dernières heures il répond à
cette question soutiendriez-vous
l'occupation israélienne de Gaza à ce
stade écouter la réponse du président
américain je pense que ce serait une
grave erreur ce qui s'est passé à Gaza à
mon avis c'est que le Hamas et ses
éléments
extrêmes ne représente pas l'ensemble du
peuple palestinien et je pense que ce
serait une erreur pour Israël d'occuper
à nouveau
Gaza mais il est nécessaire d'y aller et
d'éliminer les extrémistes lezbollah au
nord et le Hamas au
sud
alors on reparlera du hbola mais je
voudrais vous entendre je vous redonner
la parole juste après je mais d'abord
avec vous Antoine Mariotti effectivement
entrer dans Gaza alors on a bien compris
l'objectif essayer de de de localiser et
d'éliminer les les leaders et les
militants du Hamas mais sinon entrer en
Gaza pour combien de temps il pour pour
y faire quoi ce mot occupation non tout
à fait il faut rappeler déjà queil y
avait une vingtaine de colonies
israéliennes aujourd'hui quand on parle
de colonisation c'est en 6 jordanille
donc l'autre territoire PAL pour nos
téléspectateurs qui connaissent pas
forcément il n'y a plus d'Israéliens qui
vivent dans la bande de Gaza donc de
Colon depuis 2005 ils ont été évacués il
retourner ce serait forcément un
cauchemar parce que ça veut dire que
dans ce cas-là on est plus sur une
séquence de quelques jours quelques
semaines de violence mais permanente
parce qu'ils n'ont aucune envie
évidemment de reperdre des territoires
qui sont déjà extrêmement faibles je
vous rejoins totalement sur tout ce
qu'on disait sur l'intervention
terrestre qui serait évidemment
extrêmement compliqué parce que vous
avez des tunnels dans tous les sens et
que dès que vous entrez ave un char ou
une unité il peut en ressortir de
n'importe où évidemment que ce sont des
presque des commandos suicidaires
n'empêche que ça peut faire extrêmement
mal en vie humaine pour les Israéliens
donc moi je pense que pour les otages la
seule solution réelle pour en Saver un
maximum c'est finalement la négociation
parce que si les Israéliens le
renseignement israélien et l'armée
israélienne avaiit réellement les les
connaissances
suffisantes du du du rapport de force de
de là où pouvaient être les otages sur
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
leur Capac cité militaire aussi
c'est-à-dire où est-ce que il fabrique
ces ces bombes par exemple ces roquettes
parce qu'en effet tout vient
initialement de l'Iran mais c'est un tel
blocus que ça fait bien longtemps qu'il
y a plus de cargo qui débarque pour
ramener des des centaines de roquettes
au hamass ils ont fabriqué c'est grâce à
ce transfert de compétences que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure ils fabriquent
eux-mêm ça et si on savait parfaitement
où ils étaient aussi plus précisément si
les Israéliens savaient c'est là qu'ils
auraient frappé depuis bien longtemps or
on voit qu'à chaque fois encore une fois
ils sont encore plus forts donc il va
falloir en passer par la négociation
parce que le problème des commandos
c'est que il y a toujours ce mythe d'ntb
en Afrique où il y avait des des
Israéliens qui avaient été pris en otage
dans un avion et cetera et il y avait un
commando qui était venu mené d'ailleurs
par le frère de Benjamin netanou qui
avait sauvé tous ces otages là tué les
assaillants et le frère était décédé
d'ailleurs euh mais sinon tout le monde
avait été sauvé donc il y a un peu ce
myth là mais quand vous prenez des dates
plus récentes c'est en 1994 si ma
mémoire est bonne vous aviez un otage
palestinien aux mains du Hamas dans la
banlieue de Jérusalem et bien là le
commando a non seulement tué les
terroristes mais aussi le le l'otage
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué parce
que là vous allees dans une zone
terrible votre avis sur le mot
occupation bah c'est-à-dire que pour
prendre la place et éliminer j'allais
dire les les dernières capacités du
Hamas c'est-à-dire les tunnels les
stocks d'armes les les dirigeants et
puis les exécutants et cetera une fois
que vous tenez la place il faut la tenir
précisément si vous retirez aussitôt
elle est reprise et donc vous êtes de
faites obligé de vous transformer en
armée d'occupation et le provisoire
devient du provisoire qui dure et c'est
là où est le problème et c'est ce que
redoute au premier chef l'Iran c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont stigmatisé d'abord
l'offensive terrestre alors même qu'il y
avait des frappes aériennes et ça
j'allais dire ça ne les effrait moins
parce que ils savent qu'il y a un côté
un côté fugace une fois que ça a été
détruit on peut reprendre voilà et puis
c'est ce que redoute aussi les
Américains car ils savent que ça ça peut
donner une autre tournure au conflit
isralo-arabe alors on parle de l'Iran
dans un instant avec Mathieu vous voulez
prendre la parole oui non moi je voulais
quand même dire une chose parce
que sur ce terme d'occupation c'est très
important parce que ça cristallise vous
l'imaginez bien depuis des décennies en
réalité toute la militance palestinienne
qu'elle soit nationaliste ou islamiste
avec donc à partir des années 80
l'émergence du Hamas dans le paysage de
la résistance palestinienne mais en
réalité concernant la bande de Gaza les
Gazaoui y compris après le retrait de
l'armée israélienne se se considère
encore sous occupation israélienne
l'imaginaire n'a pas dit disparu parce
qu'ils sont ils font l'objet de
différents blocus parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas sortir de la BAMBE de Gaza
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se déplacer
ou alors c'est vraiment les visas au
comptegoutte et cetera donc cette cette
idée de nous sommes occupés nous sommes
des une population de réfugiés enfermé
dans cet enclave et occupé par Israël
elle n'a pas elle ne dispar c'est que là
il y aura il y aura des soldats à chaque
point de rue oui mais si vous voulez
c'est vraiment en tout cas il faut enfin
oui ça va changer évidemment les choses
mais mais je je ne pense pas à écouter
Biden qu'on qu'on aille très loin en
tout cas dans le débat sur le la
question de l'occupation qui est quand
même fondamentale pour comprendre la
violence aussi qui qui vient des
Palestiniens euh évidemment on parle de
l'Iran comme comme prévu avec vous
Mathieu pour commencer et et avec la
question des relations entre la France
et l'Iran Emmanuel Macron a a mis en
garde hier oui lors d'un entretien
téléphonique avec son homologue iranien
Ibrahim Raissi le président de la
République a mis en garde Terran contre
toute escalade ou extension du conflit
notamment au Liban l'Iran compenu de ses
relations avec le hzbollah et le Hamas a
une responsabilité à cet égard explique
l'Élisée l'Iran doit tout mettre en
œuvre pour éviter tout embrasement
régional et selon l'Élisée toujours
hmanuel Macron a également rappelé la
nécessité pour tous de condamner les
attaques terroristes perpétré par le
Hamas en Israël et le droit d'Israël à
se défendre ainsi que d'éliminer les
groupes terroristes qui ont frappé sa
population mais tout en épargnant les
civils à Gaza et en respectant le droit
international humanitaire est-ce qu'il a
une chance d'être entendu le chef de
l'État exprime la position de la France
après tout c'est son job mais quand on
lit la version iranienne évidemment
c'est une autre histoire j'ai regardé ce
que disait l'agence Irna l'agence de
presse officielle du régime iranien et
si Teran confirme bien le coup de fil
d'Emmanuel Macron à la présidence
iranienne ben la présidence iranienne
explique que c'est plutôt Ibrahim risy
qui a mis en garde Emmanuel Macron en le
prévenant que si les crimes du je cite
he régime sioniste notamment les meurtre
de personne et le blocus de Gaza ne
cessait pas alors la situation deviendra
plus compliquée et la bataille
s'élargira vous conviendraz c'est
exactement l'inverse aucune condamnation
par ailleurs de l'attaque du Hamas
qualifié d'opération des groupes de
résistance Palestiniens on se cro à la
France insoumise et considéré par théran
comme une réaction au crime d'Israël et
une protestation contre SEP décennies de
meurtrre de cruauté et d'injustice
toujours entre guillemets selon la
présidence iranienne et puis enfin
toujours selon Irna le président iranien
a également critiqué le gouvernement
français lors de ce coup de fil pour
avoir interdit sur son sol des
manifestations pro palalestiniennes et
puis il a appelé Emmanuel Macron à ne
pas permettre que le nom de la France
entre guillemets soit mentionné dans
l'histoire comme un pays qui soutient le
régime sioniste tueur d'enfants vous
conviendrez que c'est deux versions
totalement différence évidemment à quoi
sert une telle conversation téléphonique
bah les divergences de contte-rendu
c'est classique en diplomatie encore
plus quand les relations diplomatiqu
sont exécrables ce qui est le cas entre
la France et l'Iran qui détient toujours
quatre otages français dont Emmanuel
Macron a redemandé hier la libération
immédiate alors au début de son premier
quinquenal chef de l'État avait cru
pouvoir reprendre langue avec Teran pour
relancer la accord sur le nucléaire que
Donald Trump avait torpillé mais sans
succès et depuis les relations se sont
sérieusement brouillées mais Emmanuel
Macron qui ce weekend a fait un tour
téléphonique des capitales du Proche
Orient pour essayer de peser dans ce
conflit essayer de défendre la voix de
la France sans grand succès parce qu'on
est plus tellement entendu benah il ne
pouvait pas oublier les rang qui est un
acteur évidemment incontournable de la
région effectivement Jérôme clche à quel
point l'Iran peut peser sur le la la
suite des événements notamment via le
Hezbollah libanais je voudrais qu'on
fasse un focus sur cette autre front qui
existe déjà même s'il est encore
sporadique ah bah c'est c'est simple
l'Iran est le centre de gravité
décisionnelle de cette affaire que ce
soit pour la libération des otages ou
pour éviter l'escalade et donc l'enjeu
n'est pas tellement de savoir si c'est
l'Iran qu'il faut j'allais dire viser
dans les négociations uniquement dans
les négociations naturellement mais de
savoir comment atteindre l'Iran dans les
négociations or là il y a pas énormément
de proxy pour les les d'intermédiaires
pour les les Américains ses alliés et
partenaires vous avez le Qatar
éventuellement qui est à bonne distance
et qui pourrait éventuellement
constituer un proxy vous avez la Turquie
parce que la Turquie peut facilement
parler à la Russie qui elle est à bonne
distance et d'Israël et euh et de l'Iran
voilà mais tout ça nous met quand même à
distance de l'Iran si vous regardez de
l'autre côté sur le front qui est en
train de se constituer l'axe devrais-je
dire entre la Russie la Chine et l'Iran
bah la Chine peut directement décrocher
son téléphone et avoir une bonne écoute
du côté de l'Iran puisque c'est elle qui
est quand même l'artisan rappelons-le
d'un d'un rapprochement entre l'Arabie
Saoudite et l'Iran donc si vous voulez
il y a deux axes signé à Pékin si il y a
deux axes forts qui se constituent un
qui est en émergence Russie Chine Iran
et puis évidemment le camp occidental et
là on voit que le camp occidental a
quand même moins de marge de manœuvre
que peut l'avoir que peut l'avoir par
exemple la Chine ou la Russie encore une
fois donc on ne parle pas oui vous avez
répondu à la première partie de la
question sur le le l'influence iranienne
concernant le hzbollah c'est une force
de frappe qui est beaucoup plus
importante que celle du Hamas ah bah oui
ça n'a rien à voir parce que déjà le
hzbollah euh j'allais dire au-delà de de
la force de frappe et du caractère armé
c'est en au Liban euh presque un parti
de gouvernement euh ce qui n'est pas du
tout le cas du Hamas ou pas du tout dans
les mêmes proportions et puis sur le
plan armée le hzbola a a des équipements
que n'a pas du tout que n'a pas du tout
le Hamas donc un nouveau front qui
s'ouvrirait au nord euh pour pourrait
être véritablement catastrophique
d'autant que s'il y a un nouveau front
qui s'ouvre au Nord c'est-à-dire au Sud
Liban vraisemblablement dans la Foulet
il y en aura un troisième qui ira sur le
Golan donc la perspective de conflits
asymétriques multifront que redoute
israëlle et pour laquelle elle s'est
préparé se produirait donc cette
escalade même asymétrique sans aller du
conflit état à état avec l'Iran encore
une fois même asymétrique serait quand
même un très mauvais touram est-ce que
cette perspective peut trîner justement
le l'armée israélienne et et la
perspective de de l'offensive terrestre
dans Gaza la perspective de la
régionalisation puisque on on l'a dit il
y a cette
menace proclamée par par
l'Iran alors tout d'abord je pense tout
de même j'aimerais faire une remarque
sur le rôle de l'Iran parce que cette il
y a tout de même plusieurs plusieurs
narratifs le le le narratif qui
surdétermine le rôle de l'Iran et tout
de même le narratif israélien il faut
quand même le le dire je ne je ne dis
pas que l'Iran ne joue pas un rôle mais
euh si parce que le Hamas et le hzbola
sont des groupes qui disposent en fait
de leur autonomie dans leur
environnement qui leur sont vous nous
dit qu'ils sont moins sous influence
iranien je dis pas qu'ils sont pas
qu'ils ne sont qu'ils ne sont pas qui
n'ont pas pour Parin l'Iran je dis que
ce sont des groupes qui ont acquis et
vous l'avez dit vous-même il y a eu un
transfert de compétences un transfert de
pouvoir en quelque sorte qui leur permet
d'opérer de manière autonome alors
laissez-moi finir s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi finir sur j'aimerais finir
s'il vous plaît merci donc quant à
l'enquête il y a eu plusieurs enquêtes
il y a cette fameuse histoire de la
réunion à Beyrouth entre l'Iran le
hzbollah et le Hamas bon qui a été quand
même réfuté on entend on a différent son
cloche donc je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut
pas si vous voulez y voir la main de de
l'Iran l'Iran est une puissance
régionale qui en effet agit par proxy
mais je dis et pourquoi je disis
intermédiaire par intermédiaire par
intermédiaire h mais ce que j'essaie de
dire par là c'est qu'en réalité on ne
peut pas si vous voulez les les les
grandes macro catégories ne résistent
pas non plus aux impératifs plus locaux
donc Israël d'une part n'a pas intérêt
quand bien même il est engagé l'état
l'État d'Israël est engagé dans cette
grande confrontation contre Israël ne
peut pas en effet se permettre des
guerres multifront mais il en va de même
pour des groupes tels que le hzbola qui
reste tout de même dans son
environnement libanais et qui pour
maintenir comme vous l'avez dit sa
position de quasi parti de gouvernement
ou d'état dans l'état on a été jusqu'à
le décrire comme tel va être obligé
aussi de mesurer sa position
indépendamment des ordres qui sont
donnés par l'Iran moi je pense que c'est
important de ne pas caricaturer je
connais très bien cette région c'est
pour ça que je vous laiss
TER la question des acteurs locaux
versus acteurs régionaux qui les qui les
instrumentalis alors ça me faitître deux
questions je vais vous donner la parole
dans dans un instant mais d'abord
réunion du 2 octobre vous parlez de la
la même chose vous nous dites que ça a
été infirmé que c'est c'est quoi cette
réunion du 2 octobre bah
vraisemblablement l'Iran aurait donné
son accord pour les attentats du 7
octobre bon voilà et là où
je là oùiré par qui par l'Iran non par
le c'était le l'article du Wall Street
alors moi je ne dis pas qu'il y a pas
une enquête sérieuse qui a été menée par
le Wall Stre journal j'attends si vous
voulez d'avoir d'autres sons de cloche
d'autres d'accord avec vous c'est que le
sbola durant cette semaine a quand même
accordé qu'un soutien un service minimum
euh une solidarité au Hamas très mesurée
on sentait que ça sent voilà de principe
mais c'est plus le cas depuis euh ces
derniers jours alors eu et et je
reprends votre argumentaire sur l'Iran
pourquoi pas mais quel est l'intérêt
d'Israël de puisque vous dites c'est le
narratif israélien quel est l'intérêt
d'Israël de donner une telle place à
l'Iran alors espèce de de grands de
grand ordonateurs de ce sont les deux
grand les deux grands ennemis en Iran où
je suis allé aussi euh de nombreuses
fois euh vous avez tous les vendredis
mais c'est presque devenu un folklore
des des morts à Israël morts à
l'Amérique et morts à la Grande-Bretagne
d'ailleurs ce sont les trois qu'on qu'on
récite à chaque grande prière du
vendredi à than et si vous voulez c'est
l'ennemi aussi désigné systématiquement
par Benjamin netaniahou depuis une
quinzaine d'années où ça fait 20 ans
qu'on nous dit que dans 3 semaines ils
auront la bombe atomique ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils sont pas en train d'essayer
de la chercher et cetera mais si vous
voulez ça vous explique un peu les
narratives d'un côté comme de l'autre
comme on nous dit côté iranien que les
Israéliens sont les les les affreux et
cetera euh je vous rejoins totalement
sur sur cet article du Wall Street
Journal qui il y a eu quand même
beaucoup de de critiques de la part
notamment de ceux qui connaissent sa
région mais de nombreuses autres
enquêtes parce que euh tout ce que l'on
peut entendre pour l'instant des
services de renseignement américains des
réactions qui peut qu' a pu y avoir en
Iran ou au Qatar où où est basée la la
tête politique du du Hamas parce que le
leurs chefs politiques sont au Qatar
c'est qu'il y a eu quand même beaucoup
de surprises y compris en Iran sur ce
qui s'est passé le 7 euh qui aussi ne
surestimons pas Leès
clair l'aval donné par l'Iran à
l'opération sur les massacres même mais
peut-être pas sur
l'opération ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que le Hamas est nationaliste n'a
pas besoin d'un feu vert de l'Iran pour
faire quoi que ce soit n'a jamais eu
besoin et ne le fera pas le le ça ne
veut pas dire qu'en effet il y a pas un
soutien symbolique et et plus que
symbolique financier mais ils ont pas
besoin d'un d'un feu vert le de dire
tout de même de dire par vous l'z dit et
c'était effectivement intéressant c'est
un son de cloche qu'on avait pas
forcément entendu Mathie vouliez
intervenir alors j'ouvre un dernier
chapitre qui concerne l'aide humanitaire
qui est évidemment très important et
cette catastrophe humanitaire que qui se
prépare à Gaza plusieurs ONG la Croix
Rouge le Croissant Rouge l'OMS également
sonne l'alarme on va écouter le patron
régional de l'Organisation mondiale de
la
santé il y a une pénurie de fourniture
médicale et de sang une pénurie d'eau
propre pour les hôpitaux et les
habitants de Gaza et on cint une
pénuriie de carburant et donc
d'électricit
jusqu'à présent l'OMS a recensé 111
installations médicales ciblées 12
travailleurs de la santé tués et 60
ambulances prises pour cible des
déplacements ont lieu dans le nord de la
bande de Gaza où 22 hôpitaux traitent
2000 patients dont certains sont sous
respirateur d'autres ont besoin d'une
dialyse régulière des enfants et des
femmes j'accueille Steve Jourdain sur ce
plateau bonsoir
Steve l'un des points de sortie on va
dire de la bande de Gaza pour les
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
sont en train de de fuir c'est Rafa
c'est l'Égypte quel rôle le Caire peut
jouer dans les dans les prochains jours
l'Égypte est un acteur essentiel he
depuis 1978 et les accords de cand David
Israël et l'Égypte ne sont plus en
guerre un traité de paix a été signé en
ce sens c'était en 1979 ça veut pas dire
que les relations sont chaudes entre les
deux pays mais après quatre guerres 1948
1956 1967 1973 ne sont plus les armes
qui parlent c'est la diplomatie hier
auoker le président égyptien s'est
exprimé sur le conflit actuel écoutez-le
nous sommes confrontés à une crise
énorme et nous sommes très préoccupés
par la réaction israélienne qui risque
d'aller au-delà du droit à la légitime
défense elle se transforme en punition
collective pour les 2300000 Palestiniens
vivants à
Gaza voilà solidarité totale avec les
Palestiniens ça c'est la position
officielle il était avec Anthony blinken
si je ne me trompe dans le détail c'est
plus complié oui l'Égypte serait
clairement bien passé de cette nouvelle
crise à sa frontière il faut rappeler
que depuis 2007 le CER impose comme
Israël un blocus à la bande de Gaza le
régime du président alsissi lutte contre
les islamistes des Frères musulmans ce
groupe dont est issu précisément le
Hamas palestinien il y a quelques jours
le même président égyptien encouragé les
Gazaouis à rester chez eux
écoutez-le la cause palestinienne est
une cause essentielle pour les Arabes il
est important que le peuple palestinien
soit inébranlable et reste sur sa terre
nous ferons tout notre possible pour
atténuer ses
souffrances tout notre possible sauf
accueillir pour l'instant en tout cas
les Gazaouis en Égypte officiellement
parce qu'il s'agirait d'un nouvel
affront fait à une population qui a déjà
été déplacée en 1948 après la première
guerre israelllo-arabe mais aussi c'est
une raison disons plus pratique plus
politique parce qu'un tel afflux de
réfugiés risquerait de déstabiliser le
régime égyptien dans quelques mois en
des il y aura une élection
présidentielle Thomas alissi est
candidat il Brig un troème mandat après
avoir renversé Mohamed Morsi l'islamiste
c'était en 2013 merci Steve pour toutes
ces informations Myriam benrad à quel
point justement je reprends le les les
les éléments de de Steve Jourdain à quel
point un afflux de centaines de milliers
de Palestiniens en Égypte pourrait
déstabiliser le le le le régime du du
président alcc après vous B il y a
plusieurs choses tout d'abord le fait
que le Hamas c'est la mouvance des
Frères musulmans qui est la mouvance
contre laquelle siiss lutte depuis des
années après avoir déposé le président
Morsy donc pas véritablement d'affinité
idéologique à les gueres du Hamas une
insurrection armée qui est certes
moindre aujourd'hui dans le Sinaï mais
qui est également un problème pour
l'Égypte donc faire enfin faire venir
accueillir les Gazaouis c'est quand même
courir le risque d'une déstabilisation
bon mais il y a il y a ce double
discours hein chez siss parce qu'en même
temps il y a quand même évidemment le
soutien formel à la cause
paltinenne restez sur vos terres soyez
inébranlable alors il fait pas référence
à la nagba mais enfin c'est quand même
aussi un thème cette grande
catastrophe vécu en tout cas comme telle
par les Palestiniens qui ont été qui
sont devenus une population de réfugié
avec la création de l'État d'Israël en
48 alors c'est pas cité mais on sent
quand même que la référence est
implicite mais on est soyons franc on
est quand même largement dans le double
discours même si alors aux dernières
nouvelles l'Égypte aujourd'hui met la
pression pour permettre l'aide
humanitaire donc l'entrée de l'aide
humanitaire concernant le point de Rafa
une chose il va pas s'ouvrir à toute la
population Gazaoui là aujourd'hui il est
exclusivement question d'exfiltrer des
palestinaux Américains donc des
ressortissants américains on n
absolument pas de langage clair sur
l'idée de de c'est a humanitaire etire
pass étranger qui pourrait sortir de la
bande de Gaza c'est ça à noter
d'ailleurs que ce ce point de passage de
Rafa a été une nouvelle fois visé par
une frappe israélienne cé en milieu de
d'après-midi aujourd'hui on l'a appris
tout à l'heure euh votre avis Antoine
Mariotti sur le le si on cherche des
médiateur l'Égypte peut en être pas du
tout comment vous C oui oui parce que
c'est ce qui est paradoxal avec l'Égypte
et comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
et comme le disait Steve à l'instant euh
le Hamas vient des Frères musulmans quel
ennemi intime du pouvoir égyptien à
l'exception de la micro parenthèse où
les Frères musulmans ont été au pouvoir
après les les printemps arabes mais pour
autant ils sont extrêmement implantés
euh politiquement j'ai envie dire en
tout cas dans les liens avec le Hamas
leurs services sont aussi très présents
euh dans la bande de Gaza et en même
temps l'Égypte a signé un traité de paix
on l'a vu avec Israël donc il y a des
relations avec Israël même si ce n'est
pas les grandes chaleurs soyons très
clair mais en tout cas à chaque guerre
qu'il y a eu ces dernières années on en
a quand même eu quelques-unes c'est
depuis 15 ans depuis que le Hamas a pris
le pouvoir dans la bande de Gaza euh et
le gouverne seul depuis 15 16 ans
maintenant euh à chaque fois c'est
l'Égypte qui a joué le le médiateur
souvent appuyé par l'envoyer spécial de
l'ONU la région mais qui est plus pour
les aspects logistiques soyons clair
donc l'Égypte c'est le c'est le numéro 1
cela dit le Qatar a des capacités
financières qui rentent forcément dans
dans des négociations de reconstruction
ou autre qui peuvent appuyer d'autant
que le Qatar a un lien direct avec le
Hamas on l'a dit mais même s'il n'a pas
de relation diplomatique officielle avec
Israël comme vous disiez tout à l'heure
ils ont apporté des financements au
Hamas pour financer notamment le le
paiement des fonctionnaire et et ça
arrivé très concrètement avec un
diplomate qatari chargé des relations
des questions palestiniennes qui avait
des valises littéralement de cache qui
débordaient et qui passaient non pas par
l'Égypte mais par le territoire
Israëlien et le seul passage c'està-dire
le passage des rez ce qui vous montre
quand même que c'était avec l'accord
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure
d'Israël qu'on rentrit mais c'était
vraiment très spécifique sur le soit le
fil qui permet à la seule centrale
électrique de Gaza de fonctionner donc
de donner l'électricité au Gazaoui qui
n'en ont que quelques heures par jour en
temps habituel donc imaginez aujourd'hui
ou pour payer le le les
fonctionnaires ce qui ne veut pas dire
pardonnez-moi mais que le Hamas de temps
en temps ne détend pas quand quand ça
l'arrange même les aides ou oui on a
déjà parlé de de corruption sur ce
plateau il faut effectivement être le
plus précis possible Jérôme cl on n pas
encore parlé des États-Unis on a entendu
un extrait de d'une déclaration de Joe
Biden on a entrevu Anthony blinken le
secrétaire d'État américain qui est dans
une tournée au au Proche Orient bon il y
a déjà un effet des des attaques
terroriste du Hamas c'est que ça oblige
les les Américains à s'intéresser de
nouveau à la question palestinienne et
au processus de paix qu'il ne ne faisait
pas depuis de de longues années mais à
quel point peuvent-ils peser c'estàd ils
sont très clairement des alliés d'Israël
donc dans un même si c'est le temps de
la guerre il y a aussi le le la suite
qui se prépare à quel point peuvent-ils
peser en étant identifié comme alli
d'Israël B il pèse non seulement de tous
leur poids mais c'est ceux qui pèsent
sur le camp occidental le plus et toute
la tournée d'antthony blinken ne visait
qu'à deux choses d'un côté travailler
sur les accords j'allais dire de l'ombre
autour des otages autour de la
désescalade et puis la diplomatie
j'allais dire ouverte celle de la
déclaration et là il y a eu deux
messages très important le premier c'est
un un soutien à Israël voilà peut aller
jus parce que là il y a de il y a deux
poravion et de mettre en garde c'était
de mettre en garde l'Iran contre une
éventuelle escalade voilà donc le verrou
est clair il est américain d'accord je
reste sur le le le le premier point de
votre affirmation deux poresavion ça
veut dire quoi on peut pourrait dire bah
c'est juste on montre ses muscles et ses
symboliques ou est-ce que ça veut dire
on va participer au conflit d'une façon
général les deux d'abord d'abord plus de
100000 tonnes de diplomatie de
diplomatie coercitive avec 80 et plus 90
avions pour chaque porteavion ou donc
c'est considérable hein donc ils sont là
pas forcément pour qu'on s'en serve donc
déjà voilà en terme de dissuasion c'est
fort parce que si toutefois l'Iran
envisageait un conflit symétrique hein
d'état à état euh bon très clairement
Israël plus cette partie transférée des
États-Unis euh il ne ferait pas le poids
voilà ça c'est une première chose
deuxième chose Israël a les moyens de se
défendre contre une attaque nucléaire
avec une défense multicouche quatre
couche contre une éventuelle attaque
nucléaire de l'Iran qui est sur le point
en réalité d'avoir l'arme nucléaire elle
a le vecteur elle sait le faire elle est
capable d'enrichir comme il faut comme
il faut pour avoir l'arme nucléaire donc
c'est elle l' putativement voilà voilà
donc ce verrou américain il est
considérable et il opère de façon
dissuasive et puis sur le deuxème aspect
sur le deuxième aspect si Israël devait
dans la durée faire des frappes et dans
la durée devoir mener éventuellement une
guerre multifront il est évident qu'elle
aura besoin bah précisément de pouvoir
durer donc de munitions de plus d'avion
et donc cette capacité à durer elle sera
notamment assurée par les États-Unis
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce j'ai
rappelé le titre de votre livre euh Gome
clèche la prospective stratégique livre
qui est publié aux éditions euh Herman à
bientôt sur le le plateau de de Public
Sénat